i want to make sure that we talk about
the nba playoff
uh situation that's coming up because
this is
very unusual they have expanded the
normal playoffs
to include more teams in a tournament
format do you think this is a good idea
you know i think it's a decent idea uh
because
it's really unique this year well only
year
because you got the lakers and the
warriors in a play-in game
yeah normally yeah normally you would
have bad teams
in the play-ins so but now we got two
teams that
have won the championship before and i
really do think it's a little unfair to
teams who
spent the whole season trying to get one
of the best records in the nba
and they gonna have to play the lakers
of the warriors in the first round
yeah and i don't think that's fair no
no even i couldn't take those guys
um hey i have a question for you tell me
uh what you think the celtics chances
are i'm from boston
so that's always my team celtics uh what
do you think
well on a scale from one to ten zero
okay i think i understand that scale
yeah hey hey
the celtics are in the play-in
tournament for a reason
they have zero chance so
get today hey the only thing you need to
be thinking about
is when tom brady comes back to
foxborough in the fourth football game
of the year that's the next thing you
got to get excited about as a boston fan
okay so uh all right well that's
probably good for my heart i can be very
calm until then
yeah yes yes uh charles make sure i
mention
nba playoff coverage begins this sunday
on tnt
uh you are a gentleman you're you're one
of the best guys i've
ever talked to i love talking to you
always a pleasure thank you very much
charles thank you for having me hey man
wherever your career goes you're going
to be great at it because you're a good
man i love being around
thanks for having me on so you mean even
if i went into basketball
that would not be good